we had a mansion oh wow yeah my dad
bought a mansion that was dilapidated on
esplanade avenue
right by the french quarter and it used
to be like was your dad ignatius
riley well i think if we really want to
get into it my dad had a real bad
childhood and he's like
he always wanted to make some of himself
but he never really did so then
he saw this mansion for cheap cheap
cheap because the neighborhood sucked it
didn't have plumbing it was falling
apart there's holes in the walls broken
windows
but it was a mansion and we also had
this bmw when i was a kid had holes in
the seats and it was rusted out but it
was a bmw
you know n-word rich some people call it
oh yeah yeah
yeah so uh yeah it was a horrible way to
live because
everybody thought we were rich we were
the white family in the mansion and we
moved in they're like oh these people
got to have money so we got robbed
constantly so my dad installed this
alarm system
and it would go like go crazy at like
two in the morning i was like eight
going well we're there's somebody in my
living room right now like somebody
below me is rifling through our [ __ ]
and stealing our tv or whatever and
you're like he could come up and rape me
and have his way with me and blow me and
all this and you're putting on nice
negligence putting on makeup and perfume
and doing my nails and all that [ __ ] so
it was a skittish way to grow up like we
come home a lot and the door was just
open you're like
[ __ ] we got robbed again oh and it's
very violating and just
you never felt comfortable never because
you're like we get robbed right now you
know
yeah yeah i can i can't imagine that
level of it you know yeah like i think
i was like scared a lot but that's uh i
i don't know if we ever had that
yeah coming home and being robbed and
like just knowing somebody could be in
your place
i always was scared that somebody was in
our place while i was going to bed at
night yeah yeah that would not have to
look
everywhere i'd have to open the closets
and i would hook these like cables from
one door to the next so like
they couldn't open one door because it
would the other door would stop it like
just all this crazy level of checks and
balances to just feel like okay
yeah good yeah that's cool well here's a
bad one we got
robbed a bunch so we kept calling the
cops and eventually they were like all
right you guys keep calling us we're
just gonna stake out in your kitchen
overnight and maybe we'll catch a guy
what so these two cops plain clothes
detectives came
and we met them and it was all exciting
they had a belt gun and
the badge on the belt thing you know the
whole thing and i was like oh my god
i couldn't sleep then i was so excited
like i hope they catch thing i hope they
beat the [ __ ] out of them and tase them
and all this [ __ ]
and i'm just laying in bed so excited i
finally fall asleep i wake up at like
six in the morning
i run downstairs imagining that they're
gonna have guys in a headlock and cuffed
and put them in the car
yeah and i run downstairs they stayed in
the kitchen the whole night
they ate everything they ate all the
food so we got robbed again
they ate all the [ __ ] cheerios and
the the made pancakes
because they got bored and they just ate
everything everything was gone
[ __ ] cops bro i know they took the
radishes
and the chicken bones and all that [ __ ]
all the events are underfunded dude
they're under fun i guess i guess
i didn't know that was part of the deal
brutal
brutal yeah new orleans was tough man it
was a tough time
the scariest part was like the
face-to-face crime like my bike got
stolen
many a time yeah and you know these are
big
you know black urban men yes yes you
know they
they puberty like four yeah and they you
know they got
like uh some mustache going and all this
and oh yeah they hearing
really yeah yeah one kid named puberty
wilson that we had in our neighborhood
and this dude i mean was jack oh yeah
he was born with a prison tattoo on him
right right exactly
those weren't tear drops that was a
tattoo it was a different environment
yeah the racial environment down there
was just it was just black people had
nothing right right i mean nothing and
it was hard to realize that at the time
like yeah
like now as i get older you see like oh
okay these people had they didn't have
that
you know like there wasn't any black
doctors right
they had nothing not in that area that's
for sure right so you didn't have
of course they wouldn't have any role
mod like it's gonna be very you know
like
the the chain of like um
of pop like the level of poverty you get
into not just fiscally but then beyond
that where you get
like emotional just having right right
right yeah like
i would get my bike stolen i'd run home
crying and i go mom they stole my butt
she'll go dad they need it
they need it i was like what are you
crazy but now i kind of get it right
but i will say as a white kid growing up
like the only white kid in that
neighborhood you're the minority right
you go outside the neighborhood you're
back as a
as a white priv right you know but in
that neighborhood and it feels bad
yeah being the minority sucks it's like
they can just go hey white boy and
you're like
which is not even a negative thing it's
just i'm a boy who's white but it still
hurt
yeah because i was different because you
were different yeah so i kind of i
i don't want to say i relate to a lot of
[ __ ] but you know i get it relatable you
cannot well you've had that experience
where
because that's the end that's the end
thing right it's just the
i'm different there's there's an easy
way to make me feel different
yeah you know i'm not wet yeah and then
all the rest of it piles on
exactly there's more women on earth than
men but if one girl is at a party with
50 dudes she's gonna feel weird yeah you
know so the minority
is is it's fluid you know we just talk
about minorities and majority and all
that but it
changes depending on your environment
yeah yeah it changes man and i think
yeah i feel like there's a lot i feel
like when i was growing up there was
probably a good bit of
and racism kind of felt both ways if you
weren't a racist person if you didn't
really like
you know there were some people who
probably hated black people yeah yeah
like real adamant about it
oh yeah you know adapted to like old
like kind of
you know uh i don't want to say redneck
types because there's redneck people
that aren't that way at all that's true
but there was a lot of people who didn't
and then if you interact with black kids
and they were mean it gave you this
you're like
[ __ ] well what do i do like i don't
right right i don't want to have any ill
will but
there's also these kids are mean to me
yes yes and they probably didn't have
anything else to do like right if you
think if you everywhere you go it's like
everybody has something but you right
exactly can't imagine what that you know
i was hanging out with these two guys uh
marnette and tony they were like my two
black friends and we were at the black
mall because i slept at their house so
we went to their mall and the whole
thing
and we're playing at the arcade in the
mall and one of my friends
was doing well at street fighter and i
was like yeah get up tony come on uh
and these two bigger black guys behind
me like puberty wilson and uh
testosterone jones were like get up
going good
like doing the white voice and oh it
crushed me
it cr i had to like go in the bathroom
and be like all right take it easy
that hurt you know just go back out
there back out there
yeah my my two friends were like don't
worry about those guys they're idiots
they're mean i was like yeah yeah but
you
because you're already the outsider and
then you you're doing the white voice
and they called me on it
oh it's [ __ ] humiliating i turned
beat red it was brutal
it's hard it's hard being uh hard being
white
folks it ain't easy
i'll sit and tell you my stories
a song